the world is not doing well and
the conditions are indeed not easy
the rivalry is getting sharper the negotiations
at the moment are really not easy
we hope everything goes
well so that the
g20 produces
concrete solutions for
members concrete solutions also for
the world
I think once again this  There is a situation
that is not easy,
yes, we don't know yet, but dialogue space is
needed to exchange ideas. If
there is no dialogue space, it will not meet. It
is very difficult to
find a good solution for the
region for the world,
especially in overcoming the
food crisis, the energy crisis, the
financial crisis, the cost of my life.  The
most important thing is being able to sit
together to solve the problem,
not adding to the problem, not adding to
the tension. Looking for
sanctions is not the best solution.  we
sit down together for
dialogue to find a win-win solution
I'm really worried about that
Competition is a normal thing
rivalry is also a normal thing between
countries but the most important thing is
not to become an open conflict
Indonesia wants a peaceful world so
don't let
a war in Ukraine yet  finished adding
more problems in other areas this
adds to the complexity of all of us
adding to our headache
America is a friend of Indonesia
China is also a friend of Indonesia
friends of Indonesia all Indonesia's important partner
perhaps with the
cool and peaceful situation of Bali this
is an opportunity for Indonesia
to become
Indonesia's leadership in  world level
to fight for
solving
problems in the Indonesian world
for battery charge and this will
provide added value for
Indonesia that's what we are after
We are still in the process of talking to
Elon Mas with Tesla Still in process but
I believe
Test  He will build a
battery factory and a car industry in
Indonesia. I believe that is because
Indonesia has a big market and
also a big market in Asean.
jump to move forward because
with a change in mindset with a
change in a new way of working
I believe that with the power of
natural resources, the power of human resources, the
great market power, we will be able to do it.
I will return to my city of Solo,
as an ordinary citizen,
I will be active in the environmental field